let me ask you this I've seen because
this year
it seems like there's like a rule right
where you really can't go back to back
to back MVP
barely ever happened I don't I can't
remember when it's happened unless Larry
Bird got three
and I think there was a there was an
argument to be made that Hardin could
have got it again there's an argument
maybe Giannis could have got it last
year the year before or whatever A lot
of people are saying jokic
it's a bad [ __ ] man yeah man and
he's built like me so like right now we
have these two white dudes that are kind
of just like
kind of like normally built like flabby
white dudes who are like Killingly it's
just kind of crazy like yeah I I don't
even you know I saw Bill Simmons talking
about jokic and he said that he's
the funnest
player since Larry Bird some [ __ ] he
said some [ __ ] A lot of people are
pissed off about but like you do this
for a living you analyze the game like
how special is jokic and how special is
the now I know how special Luca is
because we should have drafted him over
DeAndre Hayden and I became sick to my
stomach every time
um but like how special are these two uh
White Caucasian unicorns in the league
right now it's [ __ ] crazy they're
incredible uh each I mean obviously
jokic first you know his ability to do
it all from his size you know his length
his basketball IQ uh I mean there's no
there's no holes in this game
I mean he's okay defensively yeah I mean
yeah in a league where defense doesn't
really matter there's no hope you know
what I mean so to me there's no real
holes
um in his offensive game and then Luca I
think Luca is going to go down as an
all-time great me too man I mean he's
only 23 years old the the numbers the
video game numbers in year four I'm like
if you go year four like one through
four I maybe wiltz can hang with him
they showed a comparison of him and
Lebron after like a certain amount of
games maybe a month ago uh at a certain
amount of games I don't want to say how
many games I don't remember but Luca was
like two points better and two couple
rebounds better and assists better than
them you know through that same span so
uh and it's scary because Luke is only
23. you know I mean we literally just
talk about this [ __ ] on ESPN today like
guys don't really kind of hit their
he didn't even get in shape yet that's
what's crazy it's like imagine if he
wants to get away he's in Better shift
than he was last year yeah he's in
better shape than he was so I mean he's
learning the game but it's
I don't think we've ever seen someone so
offensively
what's the word
brilliant I mean from the amazing passes
he makes to how he can score from every
single and he's a dog too and he's big
yeah he's big he's bigger than me he got
that [ __ ] attitude man because he's
seen it I mean he's at 13 Luca was
playing basketball with [ __ ] it
was drinking beers and smoking
cigarettes at halftime you know what I
mean like Luke had been a pro since he
was in seventh like for art like my kid
in eighth grade yeah like losing been a
pro since he was in seven you know
technically seven no I just saw I just
saw a picture of him and Russell
Westbrook from like 2017 when he was
like a kid yeah yeah I mean he he's been
thrown in the fire so he was built first
I mean uh he was Built For This